touche c'est une véritable bombe
dès le début de ce film enquête de deux
heures une femme de 39 ans confronte le
prêtre pédophile dont elle a été victime
dans son enfance
plusieurs autres victimes des prêtres
abuseurs sont présentés dans le
documentaire intitulé surtout ne le dis
à personne
on y montre également de quelle façon
l'épiscopat polonais a systématiquement
minimiser et camoufler ses crimes
le journaliste réalisateur thomas ch
séquelles ce qui a pu faire son enquête
grâce aux socios financement il l'a
rendue disponible sur youtube
le 11 mai dernier la réaction a été
immédiate et massive sur 26 millions
d'internautes que compte la pologne 21
millions ont déjà visionné le film
du jamais vu même à l'échelle mondiale
selon le réalisateur
aucun média officiel n'aurait accepté de
faire une telle enquête
et encore moins la diffuser le
gouvernement a entre les mains un outil
très efficace de propagande ce sont les
médias publics et la télévision
publiques et les radios qui l'ont pris
complètement et qui aiment diffuser la
propagande que je moi je
je me souviens pas de ce genre de
propagande même dans le temps
communistes
la cinéaste polonaise agnieszka holland
sait de quoi elle parle dans le passé
ses propres films ont subi la censure
communiste
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans un pays où quatre
personnes sur dix assiste encore à la
messe dominicale et où l'église
catholique est un véritable état dans
l'état
les gens sont ébranlées beaucoup sont
persuadés qu'il y aura un avant et un
après ce film choc
moins d'une semaine après sa sortie le
parlement polonais a adopté une loi
punissant de 30 ans de prison
les crimes pédophiles on n'a même pas
commencé de parler de fric parce que
dans le moment qu'on accepte la
responsabilité des évêques qui ont caché
les criminels
il y aura beaucoup de victimes qui vont
demander l'argent je pense que l'église
tremble quelques que les évêques sont
vraiment grâce à ce déboulonnage
l'opposition pourrait être favorisée aux
élections européennes qui auront lieu
dans quelques jours tout comme les jce
l'atvs de novembre prochain un
déboulonnage qui n'épargne même pas le
pape polonais jean paul ii le film
affirme que ce son règne jusqu'en 2001
rome a imposé le silence total sur les
crimes pédophiles dans l'église
polonaise
le parti au pouvoir droit justice
commence à être un mode panique
étroitement lié à l'église catholique
dans une alliance qui n'a pas
d'équivalent ailleurs en europe
il risque d'en payer le prix politique
ici alexandra schatz qu'à radio-canada
montréal